studying the overall evolutional
universe it turns out that when we look
out in space we look back in time George
Smoot measured the cosmic microwave
background radiation the echo of the Big
Bang he's optimistic that science will
answer some of the most difficult
questions in physics such as proving the
existence of dark matter with Morgan
Martinez Veltman is one of the
architects of the standard model of
particle physics he's skeptical that the
existence of dark matter will ever be
proved indeed
he doubts it exists at all the recent
discovery of the Higgs boson particle is
another success for the standard model
but the dark matter problem remains the
laureates met up with three young
researchers to discuss these key
questions what we're talking about is
the standard model maybe person I just
had from yesterday's discussion about
the lightest turn results I got the
impression that - you're dr. [ __ ]
you're still skeptical about the
standard model of particle physics and
on the other hand you're pretty much in
favor of this did I get this right
because he's the architect and I'm you
know by the time I came along I learned
it and it's just normal because it's
what your professors taught you you
think that's but that's the true science
but you're still skeptical on it no not
at all possible I think the standard
model ever since its conception has been
fully established through all the years
everything fitted in nicely
Martinez Feldman's made the last big
contribution to the standard model
because he renormalized the electroweak
interaction so electroweak theory this
is basically what we call the standard
modeling
he was the architect who sort of put all
these building blocks together in order
to come up with this theory that
describes if not everything if not I
guess like dark matter and stuff but
almost everything the standard model was
established in in the 70s but all it
seemed almost immediately people had had
ideas that it was incomplete we believe
there's much physics beyond the standard
model and so you have this tension
between having this beautiful model
that's working extraordinary well and
knowing that somewhere behind that is is
some additional information that we're
hoping hoping to find tension tension is
the exact right word I think because you
asked about our work in my daily work as
an astrophysicist I do my I do my PhD
currently in astrophysics I try to
understand how the first galaxies in the
universe form and how they then evolved
so I implicitly assume a model of the
universe which has dark matter image
which has dark energy in it that means
probably all the work that I'm doing in
all the world all the astrophysicists
are doing is probably just rendered
incorrect when there is some alternative
theory emerging that it's probably more
suited what do you think about this and
and cosmology gravity is the most
important force although you have these
new constituents in the model like that
like the Dark Matter which isn't in the
standard model but you hope will appear
it's something but what you see is you
still use Newtonian physics even when it
was replaced by so relativity because it
solves a domain of validity and so what
you're going to expect is whatever dark
matter whatever new theory comes up it
isn't going to radically change how you
treat the formation of a galaxy
after the Big Bang matter coalesced into
the stars and galaxies we see today but
to fit the way these galaxies behave
with our understanding of gravity there
must be more matter out there than we
can see astrophysicists call this dark
matter but they don't really know what
it is
they've also introduced dark energy to
explain why the expansion of our
universe appears to be speeding up young
physicists today must now grapple with
these dark mysteries dark matter
experimentalist I'm working on the looks
detector and so I want to ask do you
guys have opinions what do you think
what do you think it could be what dark
matter I take it doesn't exist why yeah
you asked my opinion since there there's
no facts on this method you can have any
opinion you want
I consider that one of those things that
these astrophysicist introduced in an
easy manner every Saturday afternoon it
is an option there can be two things
wrong I really don't understand the mass
distribution or you have a
misunderstanding of the laws of motion
gravity that is Newton's law high
Stein's laws and on the face of it I see
so many failures of Einstein's theory of
gravitation and pleasant day
astrophysics that I tend to think that's
where the problem is yes I am genuinely
skeptical I guess I often have
difficulty accepting this or that or not
I want to see proof of it and
astrophysics unfortunately is a business
where proof often is lucky I can't start
off is the simplest thing have you ever
looked up to this guy and have you ever
looked at the galaxy I just look into
computer monitors to see galaxies okay
no in a galaxy most galaxies have spiral
arms
after spiral arm is made of stars it
doesn't agree vis Newton's equation of
motion because if you think of planets
the earth goes around to Sun Lounger
yields Pluto ones every 250 years so you
can see that if they are aligned at some
point it's not going to last very long
in other words steel the arms of the
galaxy we have first question is what
the astrophysics is called lightening
problem is how come these things are
still aligned too far in their existence
the widening problem is a real big
problem and guys who are experts in the
winding problem of each turn awesome
they find out and whatever they are
trying in a nature of understanding that
or mathematically treating it it doesn't
work and yet all of them including mr.
smooth they are absolutely convinced and
it has that's something that they got
taught in their early period I
understand in science you have to have
both the things you're trying and
testing and not hold on them too too
dear and realize that could be
alternatives but he is sort of like
there's no evidence for anything you
know why do we need anything new George
moosh thinks that if he comes with an
explanation of something that it is
truth I don't I want to see proof of it
as well it's just the easiest solution
to the fact that you don't understand
the velocity distribution of galaxies if
you know speak about evidence of dark
matter beyond that we are talking here
that is colliding things and dancing and
the like you have also to realize that
the thing that explains the straight
velocity automatically has to explain
all these other phenomena in the so it's
it's not something that you would call
proof of dark matter people have been
doing experiments on detecting our dark
metal his existing particles I would say
at least for certainty of 14
years at least at this point I start to
wonder what the hell is going on do I
have to believe to this church of dark
metal wait wait you know if you have
supersymmetry you have a natural
candidate for dark matter you if you
have accion's which you need in the
standard model you could potentially
make tower fat arm there is theoretical
places for dark matter it's just we
haven't found it yet so okay everybody
happy I don't know about you dead that
comes a new measurement he's right every
time there's a deviation people
introduce dark matter and then later
dark energy right in order to continue
to use you know Newtonian and Einstein
gravity and to be able to do the
calculations in a straightforward way
and you still have to test that that
kind of an issue however I think we have
constraints even some on the dark energy
not quite as much but we do have
constraints on the Dark Matter all know
that there's one thing that I really
shock me
which is the following I've humanity has
left until the roughly mm or maybe a bit
beyond not knowing about dark energy and
hope dark energy comes about as a result
of one experiment among the
astrophysicists and at once
three-quarters of the method of this
universe is dark energy now can you
imagine that they have been over
overlooking three-quarters of the energy
in the universe astrophysics is in a
sense not like for instance particle
physics where you come as a model and
then they go verified up to integral in
the Higgs because I think we're finally
getting in the stage and cosmology
finally has notice - no it's fine that's
what's exciting about it's just like
think about when the standard model was
first forming how exciting that period
was and then it became real science
because you could calculate I believe
that the doc problem will turn out to be
wrong we'll find dark matter more likely
than we will find a modified gravity but
we'll see right I mean that's why you if
you
knew the answer you wouldn't have to do
the experiments on the observations we
don't know we're gonna go and do it or
we're gonna find out for cosmology to go
forward we just have to go ahead as Sumi
it's there and measures properties and
keep calculating that way so do you
think that it would be possible
cosmologically to prove the existence of
dark matter or will we have to
eventually detect it on earth I do
believe that it's going to be the
combination of really refining and
constraining it and the universe and
seeing its properties and then also
producing in the lab or detecting in the
lab and measuring its properties and see
that they're the same thing and then
them teeny will be more happy although
he'll still be skeptical because he's
unhappy ships like 50 years I love
professor developments attitude I did
not agree with everything that he said I
do believe in dark matter otherwise I
would be out of a job
but I mean people like professor
development plays such an important role
in physics you need someone to play
devil's advocate even if there is very
strong evidence for a certain theory you
need that person in the present data and
the present established theory there is
no hint of something beyond to stand up
mobile there is the finding of this sort
of closed off the last dog for all we
know there's a desert yeah no see we
make a bigger machine find nothing else
no thoughts of nothing this is what
science does you you're in a chaos when
you don't know them really the right
direction
but you still have to make progress in
each of the areas right so each of the
things you guys are doing you have to
make a certain assumption about the
background and you go out and do your
observations and you see if it agrees
and if it doesn't agree then you have to
think about alternatives right and you
could find something really spectacular
like x2 dimensions and who knows the
implications of things like that I would
be happy term if it's out making SIG's
exploring the next energy range even if
I am not given any indication that I'm
going to find something so you're going
out into the desert I'm going down
resave wonderful let's let's go on
it's like development analogy of being
in the desert I don't know who can say
if there's dark matter if there's no
dark night
if it's a wimp if it's an accion if it's
some kind of bizarre extradimensional
extension of a multi-dimensional
particle I'm just excited to be throwing
myself out there to be heading off into
the desert to see what I can find
you